[Music]
Coco is being held as one of the best
animated films to come from Disney and
Pixar this film is an inspiring
celebration of family music and the
tradition of Dia de los Muertos but
there are some pretty dark secrets about
the film to take a ride with us as we
explore the underworld of this film and
uncover some pretty surprising facts new
here subscribe to the things for instant
access to our videos and click on the
like button if you enjoyed this video
now here are 10 dark secrets in Disney's
Coco dolo dog history
Miguel's dog Dante is a lovable goofy
dog with a huge silly tongue that hangs
out of his mouth you're not going to
believe the story behind these adorable
hairless dogs that are found in Mexico
the history of the Zolo dog goes back
over 3500 years these hairless dogs lack
molars in the sides of their mouths
which causes their tongues to hang out
like Dante's in the movie here's the
dark secret we uncovered about these
cuddler canines they apparently have a
pretty troubled past they used to be the
food for ancient Mesoamerican
conquistadors that's right they were the
only domesticated animal besides turkeys
to be eaten by hungry dudes with an
appetite for dog meat in fact they ate
so many of these dogs they were nearly
rendered extinct all poor little guys
Mexico could have stopped to eating of
these friendly creatures in 1956 and
they are thriving again it's a good
thing too they are known for their
ability to heal and comfort the elderly
and the sick that's because their bodies
give off heat and they always seem to
know who needs healing and where it is
sit to help their human friends they are
super intelligent too known for their
ability to open doors and crates with
ease the trademark controversy did you
know that Disney tried to trademark Dia
de los Muertos or Day of the Dead so
that they could have exclusive rights to
any merchandise and property relating to
the holiday according to CNN Disney
wanted to secure the rights to the title
day of the dead and such themed
merchandise as fruit preserves fruit
based snacks toys games clothing
footwear backpacks clocks and jewelry
let's just say the luck
community wasn't very happy about this
attempt to commercialize their honored
holiday present day org a national
organization that says it exists to
amplify the political voice of Latino
communities tweeted tell Disney not to
trademark Day of the Dead culture is not
for sale
lalo Alcaraz author of the nationally
syndicated culture comic la Cucaracha
created the editorial cartoon called me
Auto Mouse which is aimed at Disney and
Pixar's controversial attempt at trade
marking the Day of the Dead the cartoon
looks like a movie poster displaying a
destructive skeleton with Mouse ears and
terrifying teeth the tagline reads it's
coming to trademark your kochira Disney
did eventually back down but they made
up for it by hiring Lalo Alcaraz as a
cultural consultant remember him he's
the guy responsible for the Miko Mouse
editorial cartoon
well played Disney John Lasseter left
Pixar right before Coco's release Coco's
executive producer John Lasseter got
into a bit of hot water right before
Coco was to be released in theaters he
was forced to take a six-month leave of
absence over allegations of
inappropriate behavior toward the women
he worked with at Disney and Pixar
Lasseter released a memo saying he has
always wanted the Animation Studios to
be places with a creative culture that
is built on trust and respect and it
becomes fragile if any members of the
team don't feel valued he said it's his
responsibility to ensure that doesn't
happen and he believes he has been
falling short in this regard Lasseter
added that he recently had a number of
difficult conversations that have been
very painful for him he said it's never
easy to face your missteps but it's the
only way to learn from them one
anonymous former Pixar employee said
that Lassiter's leave of absence
statement was ridiculous and trivialized
his behavior the employee added that she
thought it was belittling and demeaning
to sum up his behavior as just a few
unwanted hugs if it was just unwanted
hugs she said he wouldn't be stepping
down
Coco went on to win a Golden Globe on an
Academy Award for Best Animated Feature
and no one thanked mr. Lasseter the
poisoning plot a
okay what is it with Disney and poison
in cocoa arnesto dela Cruz is part of
the Disney villain club for his
insidious act of poisoning his music
partner Hector Riviera furnesto got away
with it - if you don't count that whole
thing being crushed by a bail thing this
doesn't seem like a subject matter that
is appropriate for young audiences but
hey since Disney has already done it in
the past
no biggie in an interview with the
film's co-director Adrian Malina and
writer Matthew Aldridge discuss their
decision to go with this dark plot
Molina shared that they had to have a
serious conversation about whether it
was totally necessary it is pretty
surprising and harrowing twist in the
film Molina said he wanted to be very
delicate and how they presented it but
the storyline plays into the end game in
terms of themes for how a person with a
lot of ambition could take that too far
he said for him but drama is the juicy
stuff
Aldridge added that Ernesto's
double-crossing plot seemed to fit
perfectly with the tale
he said it's dark it's surprising and it
has a wonderful touch of melodrama that
reminded him of the great telenovelas
with these big reveals not suitable for
sensitive kids some parents are
complaining that Coco is a little too
much for sensitive kids
one parent took to common sense media a
website where parents can rate films and
TV shows on whether they are appropriate
for kids this parent said that they had
to leave early because their
six-year-old was upset by adults yelling
at kids and a surprising visual effects
another parent shared that their
eight-year-old daughter was sobbing at
the end of the movie and kept saying how
scary it was the parent of another young
child said her son was very disturbed
when Miguel was thrown into the pit and
couldn't get out
he was also upset from the characters
were in peril of vanishing forever
because they had been forgotten
that is pretty heavy stuff for a kid to
grasp this kid was also confused by
Miguel's defiance against his family I
mean if you think about it Miguel did a
lot of things parents warned their kids
against he ran away from home broke into
a mausoleum
stole a guitar and crashed a party into
the underworld many kids would have been
grounded for weeks for those stunts it
seems this kids movie is a bit too dark
for some kids frozen haters the same
parents who spoke up about this film
being too dark for younger kids also had
some strong opinions about Olaf's frozen
adventure the short film that played
before Coco the gist is they hated it
one mom complains that with the previews
and this 22 minute short film before the
actual feature film she and her child
had to sit there for 50 minutes before
the film actually started anyone with
kids knows that's a really long time to
keep a kid sitting still in a seat
several critics took to Twitter to
complain about how long the subpar short
film was one person tweeted that the
Swart was like 856 minutes long and that
she was having a minor anxiety attack
started sweating and almost got up to
leave another twitter user said she
thought the frozen short before coco
unforgivably stretched the definition of
short someone else tweeted that when
someone in this audience involuntarily
exclaimed oh my god when Elsa started to
sing again it was the hardest yet
laughed of at theatres all year tough
crowd needless to say Disney pulled the
short film after getting all of this
negative criticism and audiences
couldn't be happier about it did you
guys see Olaf's frozen adventure if so
comment what you thought below
references to the shining
so apparently Coco's director Lee
Unkrich is a huge fan of Stanley Kubrick
and his film The Shining this guy is
obsessed with Kubrick and all things
related to the shining he is even the
self-appointed caretaker of the spooky
shining blog the Overlook Hotel calm I'm
rich loves to hide references to the
horror movie in all of the Pixar films
he has worked on he told cinema blend
that there are three references to the
shining in Coco first there's the axe
according to the Coco director there's a
scene where Dante wakes up where he's
been sleeping
and he kind of snaps awake and the ends
of climbing up a tree to go into the
hideout in the Attic for Miguel is in
the background there's an axe stuck in a
tree stump and it's one of the axes from
the shining
next UNCHR it's revealed that in the
same shot in the background there's a
red drum behind the axe you know like in
the movie where the kid says Redrum
finally there's the twins UNCHR it's
revealed that he hid the twins from the
movie The Shining in the scene where
everyone is getting ready for the
sunrise spectacular they show up on the
east will next to Miguel in the
rehearsal space nihilistic theme Coco is
in the first animated film to explore
the afterlife but it is the first to
take it to this level in the film the
relatives who have crossed over move on
to a colorful underworld after they pass
their existence relies heavily on their
family remembering them and putting
their pictures on the offer in das an
altar designed to allow the remembered
relatives to cross over once a year
during the celebration of la dia de los
muertos but there is a second departure
in the movie that is a little more
mystic and obscure Hector's friend Gigi
Don is on the verge of this second
departure when we find him in the film
Cheech alone is disappearing because
everyone in the land of the living has
forgotten him it's a sobering moment in
the film one that begs the question if
we are forgotten did we ever really
exist if we never existed was it all
meaningless edward james olmos who
voiced the character in the film said
you let somebody be forgotten and they
disappear they're gone nobody will ever
know about them they came and went and
nobody remembers them that's pretty dark
for a Pixar film don't you think edward
james olmos said he reacted with heavy
sobs the first time he saw the movie the
border crossing reference we are living
in pretty dark political times there is
a lot of debate about our border with
Mexico and if there should be a wall and
stronger border restrictions this is
alluded to in cocoa when the ancestors
try to cross over to the land of the
livin on da Denis Matos as Russell
pointed out the process is remarkably
similar to the border crossing system
between the United States and Mexico
with custom agents requirements for
entry time limitations
rejections if certain criteria are not
met considering all of the dark times in
cocoa it's not surprising that they
tackle this issue of border control as
well Gael Garcia Bernal who is the voice
actor of Hector in the film said he was
fascinated with the storytelling
approach especially during this deeply
conflicted political time in an
interview with The Washington Post he
said he thinks it's really interesting
to see how people like co-director
Adrian Molina and other American Latinos
are engaging and making themselves heard
he went on to say that they manifest who
they are in an impressive culturally
potent way even while engaging in a
discussion with an irrational mythology
that is criminalizing them in the United
States
well said Gail left junk LA there is one
cultural element in cocoa that left some
audience members feeling a bit uneasy
it's a disciplinary tool called but junk
LA or the flip flop you might remember
Miguel's grandmother taking her shoe off
and smacking the Mariachi with her junk
litter for letting Miguel play his
guitar some people found this upsetting
Juan Vidal discusses this in detail in
an article for NPR he said the Latinos
who grew up under the reign of LUN
jungler the idea of corporal punishment
is not a foreign one he went on to say
that many from the moment they could
speak in full sentences already knew the
string of discipline and all that
entailed there was even a PSA parody
video made which is supposed to be a
funny video about why Hispanic children
are so well behaved in the video we see
the dreaded chancla flying across the
room and hitting kids upside the head to
scare them into behaving but experts
think that this is no laughing matter
Marielle Pulido executive director of
the New York Society for the Prevention
of Cruelty to Children frowns on this
type of discipline Juan said he believes
it wasn't that parents were attempting
to inflict any serious or lasting pain
but that it was more a question of
traditions he said he's not sure what
the answer is but that it would serve us
well to question old traditions and
that's it for 10 dark secrets in
Disney's cocoa we hope you enjoyed this
video thanks for watching the things
[Music]